Prince Harry and Megan the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex have officially
started their first royal tour as a
married couple and parents to be the day
after announcing their first child is on
the way they were greeted by
well-wishers in Sydney Australia
they were clearly happy to be there but
there are some Australians who
questioned the need for the monarchy
visit their country Jonathan Vigliotti
is following the royal couple in Sydney
Jonathan good morning good morning and
one of the more popular events was right
here at the Sydney Opera House this tour
is a royal duty that at moments actually
felt more like a political campaign the
royal couple is touring the Commonwealth
countries where the monarchy still has
power at least for now the royal
couple's first day down under was a
carefully planned charm offensive as
they showered their host nation with
affection and we also generally couldn't
think of a better place to announce the
the upcoming baby beard a boy or a girl
so thank you very very much
the mounted me was in a white dress made
by a local Sydney designer and what else
do you do on your first day in Australia
but pose with koalas interest was at a
fever pitch by the time they descended
the steps of the iconic Opera House this
is exactly the kind of researcher in the
royal couple who's hoping for you can
see Prince Harry there Megan right
behind me they both look incredibly
relaxed as they greet the thousands of
people that have gathered
in Australia the Queen serves as a head
of state but a recent poll shows a
nation divided over whether to split
ties and become a republic they're rock
stars the the palaces answer to rock
stars rock stars and good people but not
heads of state says Peter Fitzsimmons
chair of the nation's Republican
movement we think that in the 21st
century it's a tad what's that word
again
ludicrous to maintain that Australia can
do no better than to find our head of
state from a family of English
aristocrats supporters of the royal
family hope the next generation of
Royals will help energize the monarchy
just like Princess Diana did decades ago
House needs to step aside and let the
young ones take over they've got more
personality so you really see the next
generation as being vital and people we
spoke with said they were also
incredibly inspired by the royal couple
specifically with all the charity work
they do raising awareness for things
like mental illness and also the
Invictus games which is being hosted
here in Sydney later this week Fiona
Wow that woman wasn't holding back
saying Charles needs to step aside has
no personality but you can see how
popular Harry and Megan are there
exactly that's why I said from mr.
crankypants I think most people were
really glad to see them there and
they're happy that they're married and a
baby's on the way yeah yeah and they
took pictures of the Koala what more
could you ask for not the big liad er
thanks to you in Sydney Australia